good morning everyone and welcome to the
ninth
Savannah Book Festival I'm delighted to
actually welcome you this morning my
name is Ann Gardner and we are being
presented here in the church and for the
festival by Georgia Power Bill and Tina
Kelly and the estate of Ralph E hansmann
we are blessed once again to host such a
celebrated authors person at Trinity
United Methodist Church which has been
made possible by the generosity of Bob
and Jean Faircloth and south straight
bank south state circuit bank many of
you have already circled the Sun with
Paul MacLean and watched on deck with
Eric Larsen but today we suspect you are
staking your claims around Telfair
Wright and Chippewa squares as you
choose among the dozens of renowned
writers who have published outstanding
books this year we'd like to extend
special thanks also to our literati the
members and individual donors who make
Saturday's free festival events possible
if you would like to lend your support
we welcome your donations and have
provided you bucks for books buckets got
him at the door as you exit before we
get started I have a couple of
housekeeping things please put your cell
phones off
and there will be no flash photography
thank you for the question and answer
portion of this morning we'll ask you to
lineup down the central aisle there will
be a volunteer there with a microphone
and you will ask your questions at that
point be immediately after the
presentation David Greenberg will be
signing festival purchase books
emphasize the festival purchase books
part of that copies of his books in
Telfair square now please join me in
thanking dr. Preston
for sponsoring mr. Greenberg's
appearance here today which is perfect
in its timing as we are in the midst of
a sometimes contentious and sometimes
entertaining and always mesmerizing
presidential primary season and
journalism dr. David Greenberg is an
expert in such matters as a professor of
history and journalism and Media Studies
at Rutgers University he speaks often on
issues of media and contemporary
politics which is the subject of this
latest book public of republic of spin
and inside history of the American
presidency in it mr. Greenberg recounts
the rise of the White House spin machine
from Teddy Roosevelt to Barack Obama
from the bully pit to the
well-calibrated construction of today's
publicist pollsters speech writers and
snake oil salesmen who excel on social
media please welcome David Greenberg
[Applause]
Thank You Ann and thanks to all of you
it's really encouraging to see such a
good crowd this early on a Saturday
morning and I want to thank in
particular Ted and Linda Moore my host
this weekend who've been showing me
around Savannah and showing me a
wonderful time so it's wonderful to be
in this terrific City I want to talk
today first for a few minutes about what
led me to write this book Republic of
spin my first book was on Richard Nixon
it was a book called Nixon's shadow the
history of an image and it was not so
much a biography of Nixon as a study of
Nixon in the American imagination not a
story of what he did so much as a story
of what Nixon meant and I came to see
through the study of Nixon how many
different groups were concerned with
this question that plagued Nixon his
whole career who was the real Nixon
Nixon as some of you may recall was
always being trotted out in a new
version there was always talk of the new
Nixon sir the old hatchet man being left
behind for The Statesman
then there was sort of Nixon the man of
the people there was always kind of a
new image being brought out sometimes by
Nixon but sometimes forged and
fabricated by his audiences and this led
me to think about image making in
national politics generally and that
this became a central critique of Nixon
certainly you know where our politicians
phony manufactured but also a critique I
think of politics in the 20th century in
our age of media where it seems so
possible for politicians along with
their consultants spin-doctors handlers
to present images and messages designed
to give us what we want rather than
perhaps what they really were a concern
with authenticity you might say
certainly a theme
you've been hearing a lot on the
campaign trail this season and so I
began to realize that this story even
though I had just written this book
about Nixon was not just about Nixon it
was really about 20th century politics
and I want to start just by reading a
short passage and despite what Eric
Larson said last night for those of you
heard I actually do think audiences like
I hope audiences like do you hear a
little bit of the prose style of an
author I won't go on and on but I think
getting a sampling of the book is partly
what audiences want as well as an
understanding of the book that comes
through a more informal talk so let me
just start with a short paragraph from
the very beginning of the new book
Republic of spin our political world is
awash in spin over many decades now
elected officials and their aides have
forged a huge arsenal of tools and
techniques to shape their messages their
images and our thinking from the White
House on down virtually every politician
of note boasts the brigade of speech
writers press secretaries campaign
consultants media gurus handlers
pollsters hucksters blacks hacks and
other assorted spin Meister's to ensure
that each utterance and pose is rendered
in the best achievable light sometimes
our politics seem to be nothing but spin
a dizzying cacophonous whirl of claims
and counterclaims each side charges the
other with spin while asserting for
itself a purchase on the truth the
growth of spin has given rise to a
series of now familiar complaints we
hear that our politics are phony and
corrupt that our leaders are packaged
and unprincipled that their rhetoric is
shallow and poll-tested and that even
the most important
events debates conventions speeches
interviews press briefings are scripted
staged and scored and choreographed spin
we hear miss Leeds or deceives us and it
chokes off the honest and open discourse
our democracy means this I think is at
the heart of what worries us about the
prevalence of political spin in our
political life today and it was a
question that I wanted to get to the
origins of where did this come from
not just the tools and techniques that
politicians are using but this acute
anxiety that we have that somehow it is
adversely affecting our democracy and I
realized that nobody had written a
history of the White House spin machine
that bits and pieces of it had been
written about people had talked about it
in many different ways but there was no
single comprehensive history that told
the story throughout the 20th century
and so that's what I set out to do with
Republic of spin now this book really
has three narrative stories braided
together into one and I hope grated
rather seamlessly the intention was not
for you to jump back and forth between
one another but for the characters and
the themes to overlap among the three
the first of course is of the presidents
themselves who over the last hundred
years have built up this machinery and
in particular the specific innovations
that each one developed the specific
struggles that each one faced the
specific challenges that each one
confronted as they use these new tools
to speak to the American public and to
try to put across their agendas a second
story concerns some rather less
well-known figures the spin-doctors as I
call them or information managers as
they might be called more neutrally the
experts who are trained in journalism
advertised
public relations and other fields who in
the course of the 20th century developed
an expertise in the traffic in words and
images and they often come into politics
sometimes on the campaign sometimes in
the White House itself to work with
presidents to see how they can best put
across their message and then the third
group of characters who are also
intertwined in this story are the
critics this is an intellectual history
as well as a political history it's
supposed to tell the story not just of
house being evolved but of what
Americans thought of it what how we
assess its implications for democracy
there were some who were very bullish
who felt that new innovations whether it
be radio or public opinion polling could
actually help us forge a stronger
democracy where opinions could be
exchanged freely where politicians could
know what the public believed and this
would help us to develop a democracy in
which power politicians were responsive
to the public there have been others
probably more who have been very
critical who felt that the tools of spin
were not used so much for leadership but
for misleading and that they would give
presidents and powerful national
officials kind of an unfair advantage to
put across their messages over the
American people who would be fooled and
would lack the resources to know better
and then there's sort of a third group
who I call the realists who took a sort
of middle position who recognized that
spin or publicity propaganda things it
was called in other eras was here to
stay and they took it as their mission
to educate the public about how it
worked in the hopes that democracy could
continue to be strong so I want to say
just a bit about each group this morning
the story of the presidents begins in my
account with Theodore Roosevelt this is
not to say that spin itself began in
1901 when Teddy Roosevelt became
president
in fact on the contrary I argue in the
book that spin is as old as politics the
ancient Greeks called it rhetoric and
argued about the place of rhetoric in
Athenian democracy and in all eras
leaders have always superintended their
images and tried to make sure that they
were held in esteem by the public from
whom they derive their power but for the
American presidency there was I believe
a transformation at the start of the
last century there's a reason that we
don't know too much about most 19th
century presidents we often don't even
know their names it's because they
didn't do that much Congress according
to the Constitution was the first branch
of government listed in article one the
presidency was Article two that always
surprises my students who are used to
thinking of the president you know as
the big enchilada so what changed how
did the president become the one who was
driving the agenda who was trying to put
his program across rather than
implementing what Congress thought best
it changes in large part because of the
Industrial Revolution and the great
social and economic problems that are
introduced by that huge transformation
in the nature of American life
and the progressives Theodore Roosevelt
among them thought it was the place of
the government in Washington to try to
address some of those challenges those
problems which couldn't really be
addressed at a local level anymore
and it was not just the federal
government Roosevelt believed but the
president in particular Roosevelt has
his own theory of the presidency
basically saying instead of confining
his role to what the Constitution
specifically said he could do he felt he
was free to do anything except what the
Constitution explicitly said he couldn't
do so he he enormous lee expanded the
field of presidential power but he knew
he couldn't just do that by Fiat he
wasn't a dick
hater he felt he had to have public
opinion on his side and the public was
growing the number of educated literate
Americans who were participating in
politics was growing and so marshalling
public opinion was key to his political
success and to do this to have what I
call his public presidency he had to
galvanize the public through the media
he toured widely he took trips around
the country as no president before him
had done he went out west he came down
south and this was not just in a
ceremonial role as many presidents had
done before him but to advance a
particular agenda whether it was
regulation of the railroads or of the
meatpacking industry or all of these
kinds of progressive reforms that helped
create a safer and fairer America he
also hired the first government
information officers press press agents
as they were called at the time when he
decided to start his Panama Canal
project for example he put a journalist
in charge of handling the press for that
project because there was so much
interest in it and this occasioned a
great outcry from Congress you know why
should taxpayer dollars be funding you
know this this aide who's just gonna be
giving us Theodore Roosevelt's
propaganda and there was a big tussle
back and forth between the President and
Congress he also staged publicity stunts
he knew the value of commanding the
headlines newspapers were changing you
know in the 19th century newspapers
tended to be partisan organs and they
just sort of championed the line of one
party or the other
now newspapers were becoming objective
they still had their editorial pages but
readers cared less about the editorial
page than the news what was happening
and Roosevelt recognized this and he saw
that his success depended on staying in
the headlines getting the news stories
written the way he wanted so he would do
things like
descend to the bottom of Long Island
Sound in a submarine you know one of
those old-fashioned round kind with the
circular portal door that closes this
was to demonstrate that the Navy needed
to invest in submarines and continue to
develop into a modern Navy he once rode
98 miles on horseback in order to
demonstrate that these new army
regulations he proposed were perfectly
reasonable and if he the president of
united states could could ride so could
any grunt in the army and most of all
most delightful of all to the reporters
who he cultivated relentlessly or his
press conferences and I want to read you
just another short passage about those
which were really kind of a highlight of
his media management most petty of all
were Roosevelt's informal news
conferences the first ever held by a
president TR would ask five or six
reporters his quote newspaper cabinet as
he called them or the fair-haired as
others said with derision to join him in
an afternoon in the afternoon in a small
room next to his office there a Treasury
Department messenger who moonlighted as
the barber in chief groomed Roosevelt as
he held forth on politics policy and
gossip frequently in mid shave the
excitable president would spring out of
his armchair lather flying off his face
to lecture the newsmen on a particular
issue walter clark a reporter for the
new york sun writing to a colleague of
his quote bully long confab with Teddy
gushed I wish I had time to tell you of
all the funny things he said he talked
to blue streak while even while the
barber was shaving him barely able to
squeeze in a word let alone a question
the journalist devised stratagems to
assert themselves Lincoln Steffens the
great muckraker who attended many of
these sessions would let Roosevelt
ramble
until the barbers razor skimmed his
lower lip forcing his shots then the
journalists fired off his queries as the
president wriggling in his chair would
be still by the barbers admonition
steady mr. president a more skillful
barber never existed declared Louis
Brownlow a young reporter who would
later work for FDR so that gives you
just a flavor of Teddy Roosevelt's style
of spin and media management of which I
think he was truly the first modern
master and without summarizing too much
I then in the course of the book really
talk about just about every subsequent
president each one brought his own
innovations to bear last night we talked
about Woodrow Wilson a little bit
Woodrow Wilson gave the first spoken
State of the Union messages to Congress
at least in a hundred years Thomas
Jefferson had discontinued the practice
they had been written messages receiving
relatively little attention Woodrow
Wilson who also believed in the public
presidency went up to Capitol Hill
delivered the address in person to great
acclaim to great media attention and
really leveraged this into passing one
of the most ambitious agendas I mean if
you look Wilson FDR Lyndon Johnson were
sort of the three great periods of
reform activity in the last century and
all presidents sort of used the media to
help accomplish that even some more less
well-regarded presidents contributed in
their own way to the development of the
spin machine Herbert Hoover I write
about in 1928 campaigning for president
pioneered the campaign film in a big way
you can actually find on YouTube this
film called master of emergencies and
Hoover of course had been Commerce
Secretary during the Coolidge
administration where he had been tasked
with addressing the relief and
rehabilitation efforts after the Great
Mississippi Flood which was the worst
natural disaster in American
history until Hurricane Katrina a few
years ago and so the film you know shows
Hoover down by the river
pulling horses out of the water feeding
poor dispossessed children and generally
portraying this incredibly heroic image
of Hoover as the man who's who's there
on the scene whenever challenges or
crises arise Hoover was also media savvy
he knew to give his speeches from the
Mississippi River from a perch where you
could hear the water roaring rushing in
the background so that audiences at home
had a sense of him as a man on the spot
and the National Geographic and other
magazines read the Randy's glossy
spreads of him in action with photos
from from the disaster scene of course
when as President Hoover did have an
emergency he proved not to be his such a
master there's a little irony in that
title and that's sort of another theme
of the book is that spin certainly can
help sell a candidate running for
president but spin cannot save bad
policy or failure of policy and that's a
theme that recurs throughout more
recently or getting into kind of later
part of the century
I discovered even some minor
bureaucratic elements of spin or the
development of the spin apparatus that
turned out to be very consequential
during the Vietnam War Lyndon Johnson
organizes the Vietnam information group
which has a rather benign sounding title
but it was the first interagency group
designed to sort of sell the war the
Vietnam War was going badly people
worried that the problem was the
messaging from the White House it wasn't
it was the war but nonetheless Johnson's
aides in the State Department Defense
Department National Security Council
would gather on a weekly basis to make
sure that there were putting out the
right message their messages were
coordinated and at one point in the fall
of 1967 they did start in what they
called the progress camp
to see an uptick finally in in public
opinion in how the war was going bad
Vietnam information group really became
a template for any big policy initiative
that subsequent presidents would roll
out where they would sir plan and
advance the messaging and a few years
back some of you may recall newspaper
reports of the White House Iraq group
which did something similar for the
George Bush administration and came up
with lines such as we don't want the
smoking gun to be a mushroom cloud and
other sort of memorable lines that
helped drive home for the Republic for
it for the nation the danger of Saddam
Hussein acquiring nuclear weapons and
then of course that come up to the
present with Barack Obama who has given
us such innovations as the White House
videographer and the White House Twitter
feed and every day every year there are
sort of new innovations in
communications technology and spin that
presidents have to adapt to so that's
the first story the main characters the
president's if you have you like reading
about presidents and what they're doing
behind the scenes that's all in here but
it's braided together with the second
story of these spin doctors who assisted
the presidents really at every step of
the way
I mean it's surprising even going back
to the teens and 20s how deeply involved
they are this is not a recent phenomenon
some are people you might have heard of
Bill Moyers working for LBJ Michael
Deaver Ronald Reagan's image master
Roger Ailes
of course Richard Nixon and George Bush
senior's media guy who then goes on to
found Fox News but there are also all
these obscure figures who I found
just deliciously fascinating and who
also played a really historic part in
the development of this vast machinery
that presidents now have at their
disposal for trying to influence public
opinion
one of these figures was named Judson
Welliver who was the first White House
speechwriter now the title of White
House speechwriter didn't come into use
until the Eisenhower years but that's
effectively what Welliver did for warren
g harding Harding as some of you know
was kind of known as a bombastic
bloviating speaker
he was often mocked by the likes of HL
Mencken who compared his speeches to
steel beam soup and dogs barking at the
laundry on the line and and at the same
time Harding because of the rising
visibility of the president in the new
mass media in the newspapers and the
newsreels was being called upon to give
many more speeches than his predecessors
had been so Judson Welliver is the
literary Clerk that's his official title
who who really helps out and even even
curmudgeonly HL Mencken writes a column
where he says yeah I think old Welliver
is having some positive effect on on
Harding I write about Robert Montgomery
in the Eisenhower years Robert
Montgomery was a movie and TV actor who
by the 1950s was kind of stalling his
career a little bit but he had gotten
involved much like his friend Ronald
Reagan they had somewhat parallel tracks
in Hollywood so he got involved in
Republican politics and in 1952 he's
watching Dwight Eisenhower's television
debut in Abilene Kansas in June it's
sort of his first speech but what's
supposed to be this grand day is ruined
there's a downpour and Eisenhower's
reading his script through fogged up
glasses their bleachers behind him and
people are sort of traipsing back and
forth like nothing nothing important is
happening and the optics are just
terrible and Montgomery sort of places a
call to the campaigning saying you need
emergency help the next year after
Eisenhower's election Montgomery is
given a full-time office in the West
Wing he becomes the first ever White
House TV
coach and he starts doing little things
you know telling Eisenhower to change
his glasses to use these lucite frames
which will look better on TV
he even has Eisenhower come out in front
of the White House desk to look more
relaxed starts playing with raising and
lowering the lectern he actually raises
it because he feels Eisenhower's been
lowering his head to read his script and
the lights are reflecting off his bald
head I'll try not to do that here and he
also gets involved in the substance in
making sure the patient of the speeches
is correct
so Eisenhower yeah he's born in 1890
he's a man of an earlier time not really
a creature of the television age like
JFK who comes after him but he
surrenders himself to Montgomery and
other media advisors and by the end of
his presidency he's actually quite adept
with television he gives these oval
office addresses that are really well
respected over Sputnik in 1957 over the
Little Rock crisis the integration of
Little Rock High School Central High
School where his more leadership from
the Oval Office in these primetime
addresses is really considered an
important contribution and that's in
large part to serve these unsung heroes
like Robert Montgomery a final figure
I'll just mention again in the spirit of
giving a flavor of this is the first
ever presidential pollster who always
you're most of you perhaps all of you
have never heard of his name is Emil
hariya he was a Finnish geologist and he
spent time around the West in the
extractive industries got into oil and
Texas and eventually moved to New York
when a Wall Street firm thought they
could use his expertise in understanding
those industries he was also kind of die
hard political buff and sort of studied
politics and public opinion and he
realized that the way that magazines
like the literary digest that were at
the time relied upon for
the way they serve a public opinion he
saw was completely inadequate he
compared it to how you test the chemical
content of a piece of rock he said you
can't just skim the surface because that
just gives you a superficial reading and
doesn't test a full cross-section you
have to serve pulverize the sample of
ore and he felt that the surveys that
were written about in the newspapers
were like skimming the surface and you
had to plumb deep inside them calibrate
them weight them I recently wrote a
little excerpt from the book that
political magazine published and they
gave it the title FDR's Nate Silver
because like Nate Silver who runs the
538 website if you know it he wasn't
doing his own polling but he was taking
all the numbers that were out there from
the parties canvasses to numbers from
bookies and betters to the newspaper
surveys and then kind of re weighting
them and figuring them out he walks into
the offices of the Democratic National
Committee in 1928 trying to sell his
services they think he's a crank and
throw him out but four years later he
tries again and is hired and really
proves to be an enormous help to
Roosevelt and the Democrats in winning
back the White House he can tell them
you don't need to spend money in
Pennsylvania you're gonna win it anyway
you know these kinds of judgments and
then in 1934 during the off year
elections he once again proves prescient
and this is a particular surprise
because in the off year elections when a
president holds the White House his
party holds the White House almost
always that party loses seats in the
congressional elections and everybody
thought the Democrats were going to lose
seats in 1934 but hariya was there
quietly saying no no we're gonna pick up
here we're gonna pick up here and he
turned out to be right so I want to just
read one more paragraph about that
Washington wise men after these
predictions came true were floored
I will never question another election
prediction of a meal her ia's vowed
Raymond clapper columnist for The
Washington Post the president told DNC
chairman Jim Farley that hariya spot-on
forecast was quote the most remarkable
thing he had ever seen in politics
hariya made the cover of Time magazine
and was profiled in others he and his
wife took to the social life of the
Capitol entertaining diplomats Supreme
Court justices in congressmen at their
yellow brick Georgetown mance they
sailed to Europe on the Queen Mary for
the coronation of Georgia six reporters
dropped by his backroom office at
Democratic headquarters describing for
their readers a glimmer free of binders
maps charts newspaper clippings almanacs
legislative reports slide rules adding
machines books of logarithms colored
crayons and index cards analyzing
political behavior in every state county
and city in America quote he would strew
maps on the floor and look at them all
day said one visitor then he would play
with the calculating machines and with a
pencil and pad and would come up with
the information that was necessary that
it was necessary to concentrate speakers
and propaganda in certain counties of a
state in order to win the press painted
him as no more partisan or irrational
than a machine his method wrote time is
simply to avoid opinion stick to
statistical facts so there are all kinds
of characters like hariya and Montgomery
and Judson Welliver
as well as many of the more recent
figures whose names are probably more
familiar to you as well who populate
this book too now the third story
interwoven with theirs is that of
writers intellectuals critics who argue
about spin as I said some of these were
optimists sometimes surprisingly so like
the philosopher John Dewey who when
radio came on the scene really saw a
great potential that this new medium
could restore a kind of town hall
feeling to this huge sprawling national
democracy
that we had there are also critics like
the the journalist and author Vance
Packard who in 1957 writes his
best-selling book the hidden persuaders
people remember that as a book about the
advertising industry but he has a
chapter and more about it about politics
in it in which he worries that the new
strides being made in motivation
research as it was called kind of trying
to you probe the unconscious to
understand why people make the choices
they do that this was going to kind of
undermine the Enlightenment the
Enlightenment basis of individual
autonomy and rationality that kind of
undergirds are our notions of public
choice after all if people weren't
voting for the candidates for the
reasons they thought they were voting
this kind of destabilize their
understanding of how democracy really
worked and put it in some peril and then
there are those I like to think of as
kind of the silent heroes of the book
these are the realists people like
walter Lippmann in the 1920s or our
Archibald MacLeish in the 40s the
journalist Theodore white in the 60s
who's making of the president's books
pull back the curtain on how the
strategy is planned and how campaigns
are conducted and has given us that
understanding of political campaigning
today and even characters like Hannah
Arendt the German American philosopher
who wrote an essay called lie on lying
in politics during the Vietnam War and
while she was deeply critical of Lyndon
Johnson and the so called credibility
gap that had opened up where the
official line of the government was
failing to reflect the on-the-ground
realities she also didn't want to throw
in her lot with the moralists who just
condemned politicians for being liars
since when she asked have politics and
truth ever been you know in happy
company
in effect she recognized that from time
immemorial politics is around in which
people are always raising the truth
putting the best face on their arguments
and that this is the way it should be in
the way it has to be if we want pure
truth we look to the judge the scholar
the philosopher there are realms in our
public life where we expect
disinterested truth but politics has
never been one of them so these are the
three stories that cover from the early
embryonic years of the Teddy Roosevelt
administration and the beginnings of the
20th century up through this kind of
crazy
cacophonous media-saturated spin soap
world that we live in today and I want
to make conclude with serve three quick
points about spin that I came to through
the course of my research all of them I
think challenged at least or revised
when at least I had started out thinking
about spin the first which I probably
made clear by now is that spin is not
new
you know we sometimes think that it's
it's a recent phenomenon maybe dating to
Clinton or Reagan or JFK and that
somehow before that politics was more
honest more pure more straightforward
but as I hope I've shown you know going
back to the Greeks and their debates
about rhetoric and certainly in our own
time going back to the advent of a
modern presidency that's focused on
selling programs selling ideas selling
the candidates and presents themselves
to the public that this game of
argumentation and selective self
presentation has been part of the
equation the second point I want to make
is that spin is not all-powerful
contrary to critics like Vance Packard
or to those words I read at the
beginning this common complaint we have
about our political culture today what
was striking to me in the research I did
was not just that presence could
sometimes effectively sell their program
but how ineffective spin often was how
striking were the limits of spin weather
was Woodrow Wilson failing to sell his
League of Nations project to the
American public or Franklin Roosevelt
one of certainly the most effective
communicators the Oval Office has ever
seen being unable despite his fireside
chats to put across his court packing
plan of 1937 that public opinion that
counterSpin coming from Congress or the
opposing party that a series of elements
in an open society like ours conspire to
limit the power of presidential
persuasion and to go even further
theorists of spin and there also
throughout the book really come to see
and come to state almost unanimously
that most of what we are supposedly
persuaded of is what we're already
inclined to believe that it's very hard
to convince a public to completely
reverse itself on a position the most
effective spin as one of these
advertising men so it doesn't persuade
it resonates it brings out beliefs that
are already within us so spin is not new
spin is not all-powerful and finally
spin is not all bad the name spin the
term spin is one that comes out of the
1980s from the debates that is after the
candidates would debate on stage
reporters would go to interview their
surrogates about which man had really
won and of course they would always
insist their man had won and give all
the arguments why and the place where
these people gathered was called spin
alley it was eventually upgraded to the
spin room because there were so many of
them and in calling it spin there was an
acknowledgment that this was a playful
mechanism that that's been was kind of a
game that the reporters were in on it
that they were entered
people they knew to be not necessarily
sincere and that we to as the audience
were in on it we weren't just being
hoodwinked by one side's arguments and
then the others we could evaluate
skeptically and even with some enjoyment
who was making a strong case and who
wasn't the audience is in on the action
and in this sense I think the word spin
is different and it's a more benign form
from what in the early part of the
century was called propaganda or what in
the Cold War they called news management
which imply a more passive audience role
I feel that you know today's spin
culture may be overwhelming and may be
off-putting but it's certainly not one
in which we have no say or no capacity
to evaluate so I think we have a kind of
deep down an ambivalent stance towards
spin in ancient Greece Plato writing
about rhetoric again deplored all
rhetoric because the purpose of rhetoric
he said was merely to induce conviction
not to teach truth it could be
conviction about something true or
something false but philosophy was what
brought you to truth rhetoric brought
you to conviction so it was a debased
form you know Plato always had his
ideals and then the debased versions in
the real world and that's what rhetoric
was to him to Aristotle his students
this was all wrong of course he said
rhetoric can be used for good as well as
for ill and it was not the use of
rhetoric per se but its abuse that he
worried about by the wrong person for
the wrong ends in 2008 Barack Obama
running for president ran on a program
of less spin he was he was running as an
honest man he liked John McCain as well
he called for more Straight Talk and
went on Larry King Live to say what
washington needs is more Straight Talk
and less spin but in 2010
when Obama took his own what he called
his shellacking in the off year
congressional races where unlike FDR he
did not pick up seats but but lost quite
a number for his party he took a very
different line he was asked why he and
the Democrats struggled so much in 2010
he said well I think we came in we paid
a lot of attention to policy but not to
the PR and the marketing and the
salesmanship of it in other words not to
the spin so he had gone from calling for
less spin to two years later calling for
more spin he went from being a plate
inist to being an Aristotelian and I
think that all of us have this
ambivalence I think on the surface we
are platonic in our attitude we see this
vacuous and often deceptive spin and we
we get angry at it and we fulminate
against it but that deep down and even
maybe unwittingly wear a wrist Italians
and we actually are capable of seeing
through the spin applauding it when it's
in support of a cause or a candidate
that we like or we want to succeed you
know if we like Obama we wish he spun
better if we if we like someone on the
other side we wish their arguments were
more finely crafted and so spin really
has this double valence and I think one
thing I hope to show throughout the many
characters and the many stories and the
long history of spin that's charted in
this book is that spin although it has
of course at times perhaps too many
times been used for misleading it's also
been used for leading that it's that
kind of presidential rhetoric that has
brought us not just some of the lows but
some of the highest highs of the last
century so on that note I'm going to
conclude and I'd love you to line up at
the microphones I'd be eager to hear
your thoughts and to take your questions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
before this primary season how would if
you hadn't written the book and you were
covering this and taking a look at it
where would you place this in the book I
mean we see highs and lows the depths
the astronomical spin on this especially
from the Republican Party is some of
this going to backfire well I think I
mean I wrote about this with Obama but
even other presidents going back to
Jimmy Carter have tried to run on what I
call the spin of no spin I have because
we are in such a spin saturated
political culture we get fed up with it
and we crave the authentic candidate for
some people that may be Donald Trump who
you know in his unfiltered way just the
words come out and and it's there's
there's anger there's gut responses and
that is is appealing to a lot of people
for obvious reasons on the Democratic
side I would say it's very similar to
the appeal of Bernie Sanders he seems
like someone who just says what he
believes you know the guy looks like he
kind of just rolled out of bed and got
up and gave a speech it's actually
interesting note though yeah about 15
months ago
I was at a White House briefing on a
sort of advice for this Obama for the
State of the Union the president wasn't
there but some of his aides were one of
the people there was Ted Devine Sanders
campaign guru and he was laying out this
line he wanted Obama to take in the
State of the Union the system is rigged
it's this it said it was the exact line
that he had Bernie Sanders using I mean
I think Sanders is sincere and believing
it but there is an artifice behind the
authenticity same with Trump you know
he's worked with Roger stone one of the
most
of some would say devious but certainly
effective consultants on the Republican
side going back to Nixon there's a real
method in his seeming spontaneity as
well you know after the Iowa caucus when
the spotlight seemed to move to Cruz and
Rubio he says oh you know he stole the
Cruz stole the election and the
spotlight is back on Trump for a few
days so he's very canny and deliberate
as well underneath his spontaneity and I
think throughout our history even the
most seemingly unco CH untutored
politically innocent politicians have
used practice and a fourth awe I mean
Harry Truman just to give one quick
example in nineteen forty eight delivers
a speech at the Democratic National
Convention where he's praised for his
new spontaneous ad-lib style and it gets
rave reviews and this is kind of seen as
the beginning of his comeback that
results in his upsetting Dewey and
winning re-election
well that spontaneous style it turns out
and I documented this in the book he'd
worked on for months with the Democrats
radio coach Leonard Rice and he brought
him into the studio worked on his pacing
figured out how to get notes that would
serve as the spine of a speech without
him kind of hewing rigidly to the
reading so that too was but I didn't
mean that Harry Truman was a phony you
know he was a very authentic figure but
that behind the authenticity there is
spin as well so I think even this year
in our kind of seemingly spontaneous
chaotic authentic debate of course
they're still pulling speechwriting
image-making it's all still there under
the surface
and I think I think on time this will be
the last one there okay yes all right
it's contemporarily with Karl Rove and
roving company and what he did with the
Bush administration and kind of going
back to a numbers game is that now with
how you see future politicians working
it or is it cyclical that it just kind
of comes and goes right I mean I think
one of Rove's contributions and one
thing that's changed about politics in
recent elections is this emphasis on
what they call micro targeting using
data to figure out which constituencies
need to turn out and that's a little
different from spin which is about
communication you might say that the the
air game as opposed to the ground game
but they're certainly tied together
because what it allows for is also a
micro targeting of your messaging now
that too is something that people like
Edward Bernays the great public
relations specialist who was advising
presidents and I write about in the book
that's something that he was on to you
know 60 years ago as well but we
certainly see a more sophisticated form
of messaging because each constituency
through its own niche media whether it's
Fox News whether it's African American
radio I mean with on climate change the
Bush administration even had a thing for
weather men to get them sort of here the
White House position so there's all
kinds of ways that media is now kind of
messages are NER tailored for specific
media in order to read specific
constituencies I think I wish I had more
time but you know I know you all have
other events to get to and I'm getting
the know for other
so but do nature of the Internet Tom
Friedman wrote about last weekend well
we'll have to talk about it at the tent
outside but thank you all for coming